I've always thought about I don't ever
want to get used to too nice of a
lifestyle because it's going to have to
go down when you have kids there's no
way so like when the girls have like
this caked on oh shoot this caked on
makeup like the false eyelashes fake
hair I'm just like how are you going to
afford that when you have kids you won't
yeah I mean I you might have noticed you
could probably tell I'm not getting lip
fillers and Botox and lash extensions
and hair extensions and lios suction and
fake tanning and all of these crazy
expensive things but again it's kind of
a matter of priority and honestly if
you're if you're married and you're
being a good wife I don't think that
most of that stuff is necessary do you
know what I mean right